patriots defensive act devin mccourty
with some strong words in support of
colin kaepernick they need to bring him
in there mccordy said they need to tell
him face to face everything they've said
vocally that they've said publicly tell
that to him directly then i think just
moving forward give him a real
opportunity in this league you know we
all kind of cut him off and didn't
really embrace him the way we should
have i think it's time now to bring him
into the fold if the nfl really wants to
be involved in this they need to make
sure they elevate his platform and let
him speak and let him do the work he's
been doing and that's 100 accurate big
cat because one of the things we've all
realized in the three and a half weeks
since the murder of george floyd is the
message that colin kaepernick was trying
to send in 2016 was 100 accurate and
should have been listened to and maybe
if it had george floyd and others would
be alive today and i think there is some
shame for the nfl and for the people who
just kind of ignored colin kaepernick
because they didn't like his method they
they overlooked his message because they
got caught up in his method and people
are more and more people i think are
waking up to to what has been done to
him the injustice that's been done to
him and we'll see we'll see if it's just
talk this is something i'm going to
write later today on pft
is the stuff we've heard this week from
anthony and mark davis is that just talk
or is there going to be action and i'm
still not sure that they're not not just
trying to run out the clock here before
we all move on to something else
oh i absolutely think they're trying to
run out the clock i have another
question for you mike colin kaepernick
some team will etean bring him in for a
tryout and then second question you can
answer it quickly
why is cam newton not been signed i like
that's something i keep reminding myself
why is king newton not been signed
i mean it's two different issues they
both should be on teams cam newton's
been a victim of circumstance the
panthers held on to him longer than they
should have hoping they could trade him
by the time they cut him it was
impossible for him to get properly
checked out by a new team teams moved on
and signed their starters and something
sims and i have been talking about the
reality that if you bring him in to be a
backup now and you take him to training
camp and he is healthy after a practice
or two the locker room buzz is going to
be why the hell is cam newton the backup
he's better than our starter so i think
those are all things that are affecting
cam newton with kaepernick obviously
it's a it's a different dynamic i i hope
that someone's going to give him a try
out and i hope that someone's going to
give him a chance and i hope that
someone is going to recognize by looking
at their depth chart and i keep coming
back to the texans
colin kaepernick is a better backup to
desean watson than aj mccarron if you're
talking about having the skill set match
so you can run the same offense if the
starter gets injured and we see how much
desean watson gets hit kaepernick is a
better option behind him and i keep
hoping that the texans have that
realization and bring in colin
kaepernick and see what he can do and
and give him a chance in training camp
to earn a spot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports